If your heart swelled three sizes watching
The Grinch, you'll want to make sure you caught
all the amazing hidden details.
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers, it's Jan here
and today, I'm going to reveal 17 cool easter
eggs and references you might have missed
in Illumination's new animated movie!
Keep watching to the end to find out The Grinch's
secret connection to Gru from the Despicable
Me movies!
And subscribe and leave a comment about the
film for a chance to win some awesome Grinch
merchandise.
The Grinch has a ton of fabulous gadgets and
inventions he puts to use in his mission to
steal Christmas from Whoville.
In one particular tribute to the animated
TV special, we see the Grinch employ some
springy type of stilts which enable him to
jump with ease from one rooftop to another
as he gathers up the Whos' presents.
The new Grinch movie tips its hat to Dr Seuss,
the author of the original book, in the scene
where the Grinch starts making his Santa Claus
disguise.
Look carefully at the model of the sewing
machine which is "Theodor", a shout-out to
Dr. Seuss's real name Theodor Geisel.
A funny little detail you might have missed
is the title of the book that the Grinch tosses
at the alarm clock when it wakes him up playing
cheery Christmas songs.
The book is called "Spelunking For Beginners"
which is very appropriate for the Grinch as
"spelunking" refers to the activity or hobby
of exploring caves, and the Grinch, of course,
lives in a cave on Mount Crumpit.
One of the roles that Benedict Cumberbatch,
who voices the Grinch, is best known for is
Marvel's Doctor Strange.
And there's a very cool visual nod to Cumberbatch's
Sorcerer Supreme in an atmospheric scene in
the new Grinch movie.
After the holiday-hating character comes up
with his "wonderful, awful idea" to steal
Christmas, we see him walk up the stairs of
his cave-home and stand in front of a circular
window.
It's not exactly the same, but the lines across
the round window and the circular centre do
bring to mind the Window of the Worlds in
Dr Strange's Sanctum Santorum.
In the original book and animated TV special,
as well as stealing all the Whos' presents,
the Grinch also takes all their food, "even
the last can of Who hash!"
And there's a little call-back to that in
Illumination's new movie when the Grinch realises
he's eaten all the groceries he bought to
last him through to January, even his "emergency
stash of Who hash".
And when he goes into Whoville to restock,
he sweeps a whole load of Who-hash cans off
the shelf and into his basket.
When Cindy-Lou first bumps into the Grinch,
she's on her way to post a letter to Santa.
Which is a nice hat-tip to how in the live-action
movie, Cindy-Lou's father was a postmaster
and she happened to meet the Grinch for the
first time at the town's post office.
In the new Grinch movie, Cindy-Lou's hairstyle
with its two braids sticking up with pink
bows is a lovely reference to the original
book, where Cindy-Lou had two wiry strands
of hair sticking up on her head, and it's
also a cool shout-out to the 1960s TV special,
where she wore two pink bows in her hair.
Something that infuriates the Grinch even
more than usual is when he discovers from
his nearest neighbour Mr Bricklebaum that
the mayor of Whoville wants Christmas to be
three times bigger this year.
And this is a subtle little nod to how the
Grinch's heart will eventually grow three
sizes by the end of the story.
When the Grinch wants to learn all about how
to become like Santa for his dastardly plan,
he starts flipping through a book called "Cringle's
Christmas Almanac".
The name Kris Kringle, when spelled with a
'K', is an alternate name for Santa Claus,
and you may well have heard that name before
if you've ever watched the classic Christmas
movie Miracle on 34th Street.
When Fred the reindeer, who was originally
going to pull the Grinch's sleigh, ends up
leaving, the Grinch references the classic
song "Rudolph, the Red-Nosed Reindeer".
Riffing on a line from that famous Christmas
tune, the Grinch promotes Max to reindeer
duty, saying "you will guide my sleight tonight".
The single antler that the Grinch places on
Max's head is also a little throwback to the
same thing that happened in the book, the
animated TV special, and the live-action film.
This time, Max's antler has been enhanced
with an extendable arm to grab the swag that
the Grinch tosses down to him during the great
Christmas heist.
And as the Grinch orders Max to get to work,
there's a funny moment as the little dog pulls
at the enormous sleigh and, instead of moving
it forward, he just ends up burrowing down
into the snow, before he finally summons enough
strength to pull himself up and set off.
It's an amusing moment which echoes a similar
scene in the TV special where the Grinch's
sleigh was so laden with everything he'd stolen
from Whoville, that Max just couldn't get
himself up out of the snow and stayed like
that pretty much all the way back to Mount
Crumpit!
A little difference in the new Grinch movie
is that in this version the Grinch steals
Christmas from Cindy-Lou's house last of all,
whereas in all the other versions, her home
is the first stop on his yuletide raid.
The new film does, however, acknowledge the
original order as the metre on the Grinch's
sleigh counts down the number of houses he's
robbed and when he gets to Cindy-Lou's home,
the metre reads "number 1".
The new movie also has a couple of easter
eggs to another of Dr Seuss's most famous
books, The Cat in the Hat.
In The Grinch, the green grump wears a red
and white-striped scarf when he goes food-shopping
in Whoville and he also dons a red and white
stripy tie when he visits Cindy-Lou's house
and both of these echo the Cat in the Hat's
iconic stripy red and white hat.
As an Illumination film, The Grinch also has
a number of hat-tips to previous movies by
the animation studio.
In Despicable Me 3, we already saw Margot
wearing a Grinch on one of her shirts and
the clothing-related connections between the
movies continue in this latest film.
First up is the stripy dark-coloured scarf
that the Grinch wears during his raid on Mr
Bricklebaum's house.
The Grinch's muffler looks an awful lot like
Gru's signature scarf from the Despicable
Me movies.
There's also a nod to Agnes's fluffy unicorn
obsession in The Grinch.
As the Whos get their Christmas photos taken,
you can see that Groopert's family are also
fans of fluffy unicorns, though their one
has blue rather than pink hair like Agnes's.
And Cindy-Lou's friend Izzy also has a similar
toy unicorn by her bed.
If you were wondering who narrated the new
Grinch movie, well it's none other than singer-songwriter
Pharrell Williams.
He's a regular contributor to Illumination's
movies and composed numerous themes and songs,
including the Oscar-nominated Happy, for the
Despicable Me movies.
Now, did you spot any other cool easter eggs
in the movie?
And Who was your favourite character?
Let me know in the comments below and remember
to subscribe for a chance to win one of these
cool Grinch merch packs.
Tap left to watch my video with the biggest
differences between all the Grinch movies,
or tap right for another video you're sure
to like.
If you enjoyed this, I really appreciate a
thumbs-up and a share!
Thanks for watching and see ya next time.
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers!